We're looking at the same basic setup as the last time.
We're making a graph with n nodes,
and again we're going to assume n is some power of 2.
If it's just a single node, we just return that node.
Otherwise, we recursively generate the two subgraphs.
Now what we're going to do is choose half of the nodes from G1
and half of the nodes that are in G2,
and connect all pairs.
So, for all I1 and S1, and all I2 and S2,
we're going to link I1 and I2 together.
We have some graph G1. We have some graph G2.
We choose half the nodes at random to be called S1.
We choose half the nodes at random in this graph to be S2.
Then we connect up all pairs so that every single node up here
is connected to every single node up here.
It gets very densely connected here, but kind of much looser elsewhere.
So how many nodes are in that graph?
Well, we're going to do another recurrence relation.
Once again, a graph with 1 node has zero edges.
A graph with n nodes has however many edges are in
2 subgraphs, each of size n/2.
Then we are going to add to that--what?
We're going to take n/4 of the set of nodes
and fully connect them with another set of n/4 nodes.
n/4 from one side, n/4 from the other.
We're looking at all combinations of those.
This becomes our recurrence relation.
It's a little bit cumbersome to work with this.
It has funny constants in it, so what we're going to do
is actually think about in Big Theta notation.
This is just n^2. It's really 1/16 n^2, which is Θ(n^2).
Let's take a look at what happens in this same kind of tree structure as before,
where the amount of edges that we add at each of these levels
is some Θ(n^2).
So at the top level, it's going to be cn^2.
Next level down, it's going to be c n/2^2,
which is n^2/4--same thing twice,
which is c n^2/2.
Next level down, we square--we get 16--
but there are going to be 4 of these now.
So it becomes a 1/4.
In fact, each level down here we're getting c n^2 over 1, over 2, over 4,
over 8, over 16, and so on.
And we add all these up.
We get cn^2*1 + 1/2 + 1/4 + 1/8 and so on,
which adds up to something on the order of 2.
So when all is said and done,
we still have Θ(n^2)--edges total.
This recurrence relation solves 2n^2,
which is interesting because we do n^2 really at just the first level.
All the other levels that we do, the amount of work gets cut in half each time.
So even though there's possibly a large number of levels,
it doesn't add up to anything more than another constant times n^2.